I was right away very very excited to be
a part of this we just shot an interview
at Joe Allen's restaurant which is an
old Broadway landmark with Cecily strong
from Saturday Night Live and she was
talking to an amazing guy named David
Crane former head of NRG one of the
nation's largest energy companies
explaining what the forces are out there
that are keeping renewables from being
massively deployed if you want to make
electricity with the smallest carbon
footprint you can Solar is the way to go
but we're not doing it basic thing we
were discussing is why has solar even
though it's grown fast not growing even
faster so that we have solar on every
roof in America that should have solar
as someone in the industry could Solar
actually solve this crisis it could
provide 50% of electricity in the United
States which is huge 50% 50% without
putting a single molecule of co2 into
the atmosphere that's insane
I learned a lot from David Crane of the
whole story of utility companies
blocking solar energy efforts I didn't
know the extent and how far it went in
the states where the utilities are very
powerful they basically get the
regulator's and the legislators and in
that state to to go along with what they
want to do because people know this
though it makes my head explode there
are solutions and there are very
specific things blocking those solutions
and I really think it's just a matter of
people not knowing nationwide there's
less than a million American homes that
have solar on the roof right now and
people say there's roughly 55 million
American homes that should why is that
what's stopping in the industry
structured as a series of statewide
monopolies that support pay for the
large power plants the high-voltage
transmission lines when people start to
put solar on their roof it upsets that
entire system this is really
I don't think we could have gotten a
more vivid picture from anyone than we
did from a guy like David Crane who was
really one of the top insiders in the
energy world climate change itself
global warming it's hard to talk about
without being confused and so it's nice
to have a very accessible way to
understand something that's pretty huge
for all of us